>> Sean: "MOVE IT DOWN," I
THINK IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> President Trump: MOVIE
TELEPROMPTER CLOSER.
IT’S TERRIBLE.
>> Sean: IT GOT IGNORED TODAY,
YOU ADDED 20 ADDITIONAL
CANDIDATES TO THE PREVIOUSLY
USED LIST OF POTENTIAL JUSTICES,
IN THE MOLD OF SCALIA AND
THOMAS.
SENATOR TOM COTTON,
SENATOR TED CRUZ,
SENATOR JOSH HAWLEY, PEOPLE WELL
KNOWN TO THIS AUDIENCE.
WHY DID YOU WANT TO RELEASE
THEM, AND YOU ARE ALSO CALLING
ON JOE BIDEN TO RELEASE THE
NAMES OF PEOPLE HE WOULD LIKE TO
APPOINT THE U.S. SUPREME COURT.
’S >> President Trump: BECAUSE
OUTSIDE OF WAR AND PEACE, THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING A PRESIDENT
DOES IS SELECT SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES, AND JUDGES.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
PROBABLY OVER 300 BY THE END OF
MY FIRST TERM, WHICH IS A
RECORD, OVER 300 FEDERAL JUDGES,
COURT OF APPEALS JUDGES, TOO, SO
THAT IS A NUMBER THAT NOBODY
THOUGHT EVEN POSSIBLE, AND WE
WILL HAVE THAT NUMBER, AND IT’LL
BE ALL CONFIRMED AND DONE AND
GREAT, AND ALSO, SUPREME COURT
JUDGES OR JUSTICES.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY, IT DEPENDS ON
THIS DECISIONS, WHICH WAY YOU GO
SECOND AMENDMENT OR NOT.
THE 2ND OF MAY WILL BE UNDER
SIEGE.
IF I WASN’T HERE, YOU WOULDN’T
HAVE A SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT
NOW, YOU WOULDN’T HAVE A RIGHT
TO GUNS.
WHETHER YOU HAD IT OR IT WAS
TOTALLY OBLITERATED, IT WOULD BE
A DIFFERENT FORM THEN YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW.
I’VE KEPT IT TOTALLY AS IT WAS,
AND IT’S SOMETHING I’M VERY
PROUD OF, AND I THINK IT IS A
REAL VOTING ISSUE,
SECOND AMENDMENT.
LIFE, YOU LOOK AT THAT, SO THESE
JUDGES ARE GOING TO BE MAKING
MASSIVE DECISIONS, AND THE NEXT
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
GET ONE, TWO, THREE, OR FOUR
JUSTICES OF THE SUPREME COURT.
I HAVE TWO.
THAT IS ACTUALLY CONSIDERED A
LOT.
YOU’VE HAD MANY -- YOU’VE HAD
MANY PRESIDENTS, FRANKLY, WHERE
THEY DIDN’T HAVE -- I THINK THEY
HAD NONE, MANY OF THEM HAD NONE,
YOU KNOW, THEY STAY ON THERE A
LONG TIME.
YOU DON’T HAVE MANY, AND THEY
STAY ON THERE FOR A LONG TIME.
SO, YOU HAD PRESIDENTS WITH NONE
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, BUT I’VE ALREADY
HAD TWO, AND YOU COULD HAVE,
LITERALLY, ANYWHERE FROM 1 TO
FOR ADDITIONAL -- AND THAT
CHANGES THE ENTIRE FABRIC
OF THE NATION FOR MANY YEARS.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ON THE COURT
FOR 25, 30, 40 YEARS DEPENDING
ON THE AGE, DEPENDING ON WHAT
AGE YOU CHOOSE, AND FRANKLY,
MOST OF THEM ARE YOUNG, BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO PICK YOUNG, YOU WANT
THEM ON AS LONG AS YOU CAN HAVE
THEM ON.
SO, IT’S A VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
THING THAT’S HAPPENING, AND I
FELT THAT I SHOULD ANNOUNCE THE
LIST -- FROM WHICH I WILL ONLY
PICK.
SO, WE HAD 22 OR 23, NOW I ADDED
20, SO WE HAVE ABOUT 43.
IT WILL ONLY BE FROM THAT LIST
THAT I HOPE IT, WHETHER IT IS
ONE, TWO, THREE, OR FOUR, IT
WILL ONLY BE FROM THAT LIST.
SO EVERYONE CAN LOOK AT THAT
LIST, AND THEY WILL BE HAPPY OR
NOT HAPPY.
JOE HAS TO PUT AT PLAYLIST.
THIS IS SOMETHING I CAME UP WITH
THE LAST ELECTION.
I THINK IT MIGHT BE ONE OF THE
REASONS FOR MY SUCCESS IN THE
ELECTION, BECAUSE PEOPLE WEREN’T
SURE WHO I WOULD PICK, AND I PUT
OUT A LIST OF 20, AND THEN 25,
AND I SAID COME ONLY FROM THAT
LIST.
WELL COME ONLY FROM THIS LIST
AND THE PREVIOUS LIST LIVE PICK.
JOE HAS TO COME UP NOW WITH A
LIST -- HE SHOULD COME UP WITH A
LIST, OTHERWISE PEOPLE CAN’T
VOTE FOR HIM.
BUT THE REASON HE POSSIBLY WON’T
IS BECAUSE HE’S GOING TO COME UP
WITH FAR RADICAL LEFT JUDGES.
I MEAN, THESE WILL BE PEOPLE
THAT ARE VERY, VERY FAR TO THE
LEFT, THAT ARE, YOU KNOW,
REVOLUTIONARY AND A SENSE, I
THINK, AND HE’S GOT TO COME UP
WITH THEM.
I DON’T KNOW THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO ALLOW, BECAUSE THEY CONTROL
HIM TOTALLY, THEY CONTROL
JOE BIDEN, HE IS NOT CONTROLLED,
HE IS NOT IN CONTROL OF HIMSELF.
HE IS CONTROLLED BY THE RADICAL
LEFT, IT IS A VERY DANGEROUS
PART OF OUR SOCIETY, AND HE IS
TOTALLY CONTROLLED, AND HE IS
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO NAME
DEMOCRATS JUDGES THAT ARE IN THE
MIDDLE SOMEPLACE, OR NORMALIZED,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE THAT ARE, LIKE,
NORMAL PEOPLE.
HE WILL BE FORCED TO PICK
EXTREMELY RADICAL LEFT JUDGES,
AND I DON’T THINK YOU CAN GET
ELECTED IF YOU DO THAT.
IF YOU DO WHAT HE HAS TO DO,
WHICH IS NAMED JUDGES THAT HE’S
GOING TO PICK, OR THE JUSTICES,
SOON TO BE, THAT HE’S GOING TO
PICK, I DON’T THINK -- I DON’T
THINK HE WOULD BE ELECTABLE.
SO HE’S GOT A REAL PROBLEM.
>> Sean: LET ME GO TO THE
ISSUE OF NATIONAL DEFENSE.
AS PRESIDENT, THE LARGEST
MILITARY BUILDUP SINCE THE
REAGAN YEARS.
FIRST PAY RAISE IN MANY, MANY
YEARS FOR OUR MILITARY.
HE RESOLVES THE VA HOSPITAL
SCANDAL THAT EXISTED IN THE
BIDEN-OBAMA YEARS.
YEAR HE MOVED WITH THE
ENGAGEMENT.
WHICH ALLOWS YOU TO BEAT THE
CALIPHATE IN SYRIA, WHICH JOE
AND BARACK WERE NOT ABLE TO DO,
YOU GOT SOLEIMANI, BAGHDADI, AND
ASSOCIATES, THE AL QAEDA LEADER
IN YEMEN, AND YOU ARE PULLING
AMERICA OUT OF LONG, PROTECTED
WARS BY THE USE OF MILITARY
TECHNOLOGY.
BUT THE STORY IS CLAIMING THAT
YOU DISPARAGED MORE FALLEN
SOLDIERS.
’S >> President Trump: YEAH,
IT’S A TOTAL LIE, TOTAL THIS
INFORMATION.
THEY PUT IT OUT, THEN THEY DO
COMMERCIALS ON IT, AND TO
THINK -- NOBODY THAT I KNOW
COULD HAVE SAID THOSE THINGS.
LOOKED DOWN AT SOLDIERS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEAD FOR DECADES AND
DECADES AND DECADES.
REAL HEROES.
AND THEY MADE IT UP.
THEY MADE UP THE STORY.
AND WE HAVE 21 PEOPLE -- I THINK
YOU SAW, MUCH MORE THAN THAT,
THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE THERE,
AND THE SECRET SERVICE WOULDN’T
LET ME TAKE THE TRIP BECAUSE OF
THE DANGERS OF GOING THROUGH
VERY CROWDED PARTS -- CERTAIN
PART OF YOUR OUTCOME AS YOU
KNOW, WE WERE IN PARIS, AND THEY
SAID WE CAN’T DO IT, BECAUSE THE
HELICOPTER COULDN’T FLY.
IT WAS RAINING AS HARD AS I’VE
EVER SEEN IT RAIN.
IT WAS FOGGY, SO FOGGY YOU
COULDN’T SEE ANYTHING.
IT WAS SERIOUS PARIS FOG, AND
LIKE YOU COULDN’T SEE ANYTHING,
SO I KNEW IMMEDIATELY YOU
COULDN’T TAKE THE HELICOPTER,
THE DRIVE WOULD HAVE BEEN A VERY
LONG ONE -- HAD NOTHING ELSE TO
DO, I WENT THERE FOR THAT.
I WENT TO ANOTHER CEMETERY, BY
THE WAY, IT WAS POURING,
NOT NEARLY AS HARD, AND I MADE A
NO UMBRELLAS, KNOW ANYTHING.
THEY SAID, IT’S JUST
DISINFORMATION, I DIDN’T WANT TO
GET MY HAIR WET.
I GOT IN MY HAIR WET PLENTY OF
TIMES, I’VE HAD PLENTY OF
SPEECHES IN THE RAIN, AND IF I
DIDN’T, YOU WOULDN’T BE
PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW, THAT I CAN
TELL YOU, SO WITH
DISINFORMATION.
THEY MADE UP A STORY ABOUT TWO
DISGUSTING WORDS THAT THEY SAY I
SAID, AND I DIDN’T.
WHEN I MANY WITNESS -- WE HAVE
21 WITNESSES, THEY ONLY HAVE
SOURCES.
SOURCES SAY.
THERE WERE NO SOURCES.
THEY MADE IT OUT.
IT’S A BAD GUY.
IT’S A BAD, FAILING MAGAZINE
CALLED "THE ATLANTIC," AND OF
COURSE, THE MEDIA PICKS IT UP,
AND THEY DO TELEVISION
COMMERCIALS.
WEEK WITH THEM A NOTICE, DON’T
DO IT, TAKE IT DOWN.
I’VE WORKED TOO HARD ON THE
MILITARY AND MAKING IT REALLY
GREAT AGAIN, IT WAS TOTALLY
DEPLETED WHEN I TOOK OVER.
IT WAS DEPLETED, IT WAS TIRED,
IT WAS EXHAUSTED FROM ALL OF
THESE ENDLESS WARS WERE OUR
SOLDIERS ARE BEING BROUGHT BACK,
BECAUSE I CAN’T STAND TO SEE
THEM COMING BACK, WHEN THEY ARE
NOT REALLY FIGHTING, THEY ARE
REALLY SERVING AS POLICE FORCES
OVER THERE.
WE ARE NOT FIGHTING TO WIN, AND
THEY HAVEN’T FOUGHT TO WIN.
BUT I KNOCKED OUT ISIS, KILL
SOLEIMANI, KILLED AL-BAGHDADI,
DID THINGS OBAMA CAN’T EVEN
THINK ABOUT DOING.
WHEN I TOOK OVER, I SYSTEMS ALL
OVER SYRIA, ALL OVER IRAQ.
BUT I WANTED TO GET OUT OF
THERE, WE’VE DONE IT, LET THEM
PROTECT THEMSELVES, THERE’S
PLENTY OF COUNTRIES OVER THERE
THAT CAN DO IT.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE VIOLENCE THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON WELL OVER 100 DAYS IN
AMERICAN CITIES, YOU NEW YORK,
OBVIOUSLY CHICAGO, WE HAVE
PORTLAND, WE HAVE SEATTLE, WE
HAVE LOS ANGELES, WE HAD
KENOSHA.
THREE CITIES THAT DID REQUEST
YOUR HELP AND ASSISTANCE, D.C.,
MINNESOTA, KENOSHA, YOU WERE
ABLE TO SEND IN THE GUARD, THEY
RESTORED ORDER.
YOU’VE BEEN BEGGING THE
DeFAZIOS AND MAYOR LIGHTFOOT,
TED WHEELER, THE MAYOR OF
SEATTLE, PRETTY MUCH BEGGING
THEM TO ALLOW YOU TO HELP THEM
RESTORE ORDER.
JOE BIDEN SAID AT ONE POINT
POLICE BECOME THE ENEMY.
WANTS TO REALLOCATE FUNDS.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS FOR THE
REALLOCATION OF DEFUNDING THE
L.A.P.D., $150 MILLION, GOT A
BILLION DOLLARS NOW CUT FROM THE
NEW YORK PD.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT THESE
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS STEADFASTLY
REFUSE YOUR OFFERED ASSISTANCE
TO RESTORE ORDER?
>> President Trump: WELL,
KENOSHA IS A GREAT EXAMPLE.
THAT WAS READY TO BURN DOWN
AFTER THREE NIGHTS, AND WE WENT
IN WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD AND
JUST CLOSED IT I WOULD.
IT TOOK, LIKE, SO QUICK, AND
MINNEAPOLIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
IT WAS BURNING FOR TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE NATIONAL GUARD CAME
IN, AND ONCE THE NATIONAL GUARD
CAME IN, IT WAS OVER.
IT TOOK, YOU SAW IT, 45 MINUTES
TO ONE HOUR, AND IT WAS ALL
OVER.
THIS WAS GOING ON FOR WEEKS.
WE WOULD DO THE SAME THING -- WE
WERE READY TO GO TO SEATTLE,
THEY TOOK OVER 20%, A BIG CHUNK
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE CITY, AND
WE TOLD THEM WE ARE COMING IN,
AND THEN, THEY SENT THEIR
POLICE, AND THEIR POLICE ARE
FINE, THEY ARE GOOD, IF THEY LET
THEM DO WHAT THEY ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING, BUT THEY DON’T DO
THAT.
THEY ARE ALL DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES, AND THEY ARE NOT A WELL
RUN, AND THEY ARE VERY, VERY,
VERY UNSAFE, BECAUSE THE LEVEL
IS SO RIDICULOUS.
THEY DO WANT TO DEFUND THE
POLICE, AND I’VE NEVER SEEN
SOMEBODY THAT COULD CHANGE LIKE
BIDEN.
NOW, I DON’T ACTUALLY THINK HE
IS AWARE OF WHAT HE IS EVEN
SAYING, TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
BUT I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE IT, WHERE HE TALKS ABOUT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE OR NOT
DOING MUCH FOR THE POLICE, AND
THEN, ALL OF A SUDDEN, HE SEES
WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH HIS POLL
NUMBERS, BECAUSE AS YOU SEE, WE
ARE GOING WAY UP, I THINK WE ARE
LEADING IN FLORIDA, LEADING IN
WISCONSIN, LEADING IN
PENNSYLVANIA, LEADING IN
NORTH CAROLINA, I THINK WE ARE
LEADING IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, WE ARE
LEADING BY A LOT, WE ARE REALLY
LEADING BY A LOT IN OHIO, I
GUESS I POLL A LITTLE WHILE AGO,
I THINK WE ARE LEADING ALL OVER
THE PLACE, FRANKLY, FOR THE
FAKE NEWS DOESN’T LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
I MUST TELL YOU, FOX DOES AMONG
THE WORST POLLSTERS OF ALL, I
DON’T KNOW WHO AT FOX IS DOING
IT, BUT THEY ARE TERRIBLE
POLLSTERS, AND A HALF AND,
FRANKLY, EVEN FOUR YEARS AGO,
PROBABLY THE SAME GROUP, BUT
THEY DON’T HAVE A CLUE, YOUR
POLLSTERS --
>> Sean: HE IS SEPARATE AND
APART FROM THE -- I’VE KNOWN HIM